the reason why you don't have an opinion
on this paltin thing you want to use
these jokes as a shield but the truth is
you're just a coward and I want to let
you know something you know what silence
is violence this yeah silence is
violence go ahead and keep quiet and
watch How I bleed if with everything
happening in Palestine Israel right
there's been a lot of different takes
right some people are being pro Hamas
some people are being pro- Israel some
people being pro palestin they don't
want innocent people a lot of people
just don't want innocent people to
suffer okay and there's a lot to talk
about all right GE politically it's a
very complex issue here in Montreal all
right our city uh there was an incident
involving a woman uh she had a
Palestinian flag on her car and as she
came out to her vehicle somebody was
double parked right beside her okay now
the lady who's getting into her car the
one with the palan flag looks at the
other he's like oh do you want my
parking spot she's like no I'd like to
talk and this video ensued host it
Arthur Lauren wise that's my Instagram
author Lauren wise you should be rap and
drag through the streets in front of
your
kids she said you should be
graped in front of your kids that is
wild that yo for flying a flag mind you
there's no words before this that we
really share okay thank you thank you
for your name thank you have a nice day
I think you should [__] all of you
idiots who think that
is so she just said this crazy lady she
just comes out of nowhere she starts
attacking me that's what the lady said
in French I'm
[Music]
not
thank
okay okay do you have any she post on
Instagram well her uh Instagram is
locked what about her Twitter oh yeah
that's locked too okay so she
deactivated her social she she put her
name in the video post it author laen
wise that's my Instagram and then when
the backlash came she's like oh wait
maybe I shouldn't have done maybe maybe
that's not a good idea I said it on my
chest then author Lauren wise I'm not so
proud now so supposedly this lady
afterwards the the one in the car with
the the paline flex she got out she like
if you want to talk why don't we just
talk get out of the car we didn't have a
conversation and the lady freaked out
and apparently she went in reverse and
then slammed on the gas pedal removing
her car door and drove off yeah Lauren
wise
yeah yep [__] crazy right that's crazy
um why why are we bringing this up cuz
the response to this conflict you know
which is incredibly polarizing has
people drawn in such extreme camps that
if you don't talk you're condoning
violence y if you speak for the wrong
side you're condoning violence it
doesn't matter what you say a large
contingent of people are going to call
you a piece of [__] and one of the worst
human beings alive for essentially
liking the death of of babies or
whatever you know what I mean like this
issue even more so than Ukraine Russia
anything I've ever seen before is the
issue that polarizes people the most
yeah and has been going on yeah remember
the pandemic we had that where there
some flareups and people were like why
you guys haven't spoken about it why
like bro I'm not I'm not that educated
on it like you know one of the things
that is most fascinating to me about
this is people who have zero
geopolitical knowledge they don't even
understand the history they don't even
understand when Israel was founded they
don't understand how the Palestinians
ended up where they were they don't
understand none of the they can't even
point it to you on the map but they're
so certain about which side is right and
which side is wrong and how black and
white it is and they'll shout you down
from The High Heavens to be like you're
garbage that's the part that fascinates
me the most I've seen some people be
like oh Hamas is based or whatever I was
like I've seen there was some sort of
Rave or desert party where they were
having a great time until the resistance
came in electrified hang gliders and
took at least several dozen
hipsters but I'm sure they're doing very
fine despite what the New York Post
says but nobody had seen this coming
they said we control every inch of
Palestine no they they said we have
walls they were so
arrogant but just less than 24 hours ago
on the land from the sea and from the
air the people of the Goda
[Applause]
what is based about grabbing civilians
and then murdering graping all this
other stuff and then other people like
Israel has the right to do whatever it
wants like what what's great about
bombing places indiscriminately and then
also taking away settlements and then
you like the way they've been
encroaching on Palestinian land and just
stealing places like nobody can say to
me that Israel's been wanting peace for
all this time like I think this's way
I'll say about the conflict this is my
my two sense I think there's a giant
difference between the governments the
governing bodies and the people itself I
think almost most of the majority of
people in Israel the citizens and most
of the people in Palestine support a
two-state solution uh the government
seemed to have a different idea in mind
and that seems to be pretty consistent I
think at every turn uh the Israeli
government has made efforts to encroach
on Palestinian land and steal more
settlements which a lot of the people in
Israel have been protesting against and
for the Palestinians like they would
support being able to live alongside for
many of them the some that won't uh if
it meant that they could be free so you
know unfortunately you're
just a man named BB kind of holds the
range to this whole thing is deciding
how this thing's going to go forward and
at the end of the day it's mostly going
to be innocent people who have nothing
to do with this conflict or not involved
who are going to suffer so I think you
could do two multiple things I think you
condemn what Hamas did in terms of the
attack and also understand the
frustrations of Palestinian people of
being in what is an open air prison for
the last 60 70 years um our Discord is
up a lot of political discussions going
on all about all kinds of stuff also
people gaming CH chatting about
different Abba and preach topics as well
as anything under the Sun so check the
link in the description below for that I
just think it's kind of cringe when
people are just like Merk these people
and I'll also say as a Canadian it was
really cringe watching Parliament flight
Israeli flags that was really that that
was gross okay right after the yeah
every time something happened in
Palestine I see none these [__]
fly no flags for the Palestinian people
s Israel all of a sudden they want to
you know throw up all these I'm like
that's that's that's what politics is
basically but whatever yeah I digress
why don't you speak out on this topic
cuz one I'm not well educated on it too
I think both sides are wrong why would I
I'm going talk about some [__] I don't
know let me talk about some [__] I know
let me let you know what I you know what
I know I know how to make people laugh I
know how to I you never made me laugh a
single time can you really call yourself
a comedian yeah cuz I'm not talking to
you okay then go clown let's go make us
laugh
anyways yeah that's what I thought the
reason why you don't have an opinion on
this pal thing you want to use these
jokes as a shield but the truth is
you're just a [__] coward and I want
to let you know something you know what
silence is violence this yeah silence is
violence go ahead and keep quiet and
watch How I bleed this is every this is
everyday every day on social media
that's you that's you guys go ahead go
oh you're not going to put that dirty
ass finger in my face I put it in front
of mine and I blow s don't trouch me
like that man stay your ground I'm about
you're like a go ahead go ahead go ahead
brother okay are you done are you done
I'm not done are you done I'm not done I
think it's time for you to stop no I'm
not why you you should stop talking so
you can let more paltin babies
die that's you guys that's you guys
every day no I ain't I ain't saying
stuff cuz yeah it's not my place to say
stuff not every out of all the people
out of all the people all the people
that can say stuff and that are actually
that have the knowledge to say stuff go
watch them go watch them action is
complicit in the murder you know what I
mean so yeah that's pretty much what I
got to say about that I the ghost of the
bitter
activist the ghost of the bitter
activist that's now you know that you
are complicit in the death of all these
babies
sure little Osama is
watching I understand I understand the
frustrations of a lot of people who are
pro Palestine and feel like when [__]
happens in Palestine there doesn't seem
to be as much of a support right you
know when they're when they're being
evacuated from their homes their homes
are being burned down murder and then
they're having Israeli like I that
frustration is real the fact that it
feels like on the international stage it
feels like a lot of governing bodies
will turn a blind eye to a lot of the
stuff Israel does and then I also
understand the Israeli settlements where
they're just like you know they're
living out there in Tel Aviv and they're
getting Rockets sent to them or you know
bombings and all that stuff like it it's
understandable I just I I can't for the
life of me look at a lot of people who
want to look at this issue and be like w
I'm 100% right the other side's got to
disappear it's like that's crazy to me
and for everybody's asking me about the
editor contest it's still going on you
can make unlimited amount of entries up
until the end of October after that
point we're going to be selecting the
people who are going to be moving on to
phase two the goal with this so I make
it clear for everyone is to find an
editer who can be autonomous who can
work remotely and manage the things find
the right kind of Clips so the things
that we're looking for in an editor are
one creativity when it comes to the
editing process two good clip selection
and what constitutes clip selection
sometimes it's a matter of like making
sure you get enough of us and not just
the content we're reacting to but also
finding clips that people want to watch
we want to be sure that you understand
the platforms that you're editing and
posting on and that you can see a clip
see that it's going to be good content
and then upload it to the right spot so
that people do want to click on those
and so you know be smart about your clip
selection be be good about your editing
you know if you want to add in pizaz to
make the clip more interesting
definitely do that and like I said we're
not limiting the amount of entries you
can make from a single uh channel that
you create for this contest so do this
much use the hasht Abba and preach video
contest someone said this too but
they're like yeah they're doing this for
their own safety you know they can't
allow this like you have to imagine most
of the people who are in Palestine right
now are like under are kids yeah 50% of
them are kids 90% of them were not even
around when the first initial War
happened with Israel and they're still
living in this prison yeah so you have
think about crazy that is that
generation to Generation all of you are
living in Perpetual prison-like State
okay you're born you've done nothing
you're imprisoned in this area yeah
because of something your
great-grandfather or whatever it's
like as weird as it [__] up it is to
say it's almost like paying reparations
for something your great grandparents
did and like a lot of people in America
would never be okay with that where they
expect a lot the Palestinian people to
have to accept that kind of situation
based a lot of people in America are not
for that yeah I know that's what I'm
saying they don't want to they they
would never want don't want to pay I
haven't done nothing to you yeah so I
it's just and I understand yeah people
don't have an opinion I I don't think
you should feel bad I don't think it's
your job to be educated on this if you
don't want to if you don't feel some
type of weight if you're someone listen
let's be honest I think a lot of you are
watching this right now you're like I'm
exhausted of the depressing feeling I
get when I see international news I'm
get when I look at this issue that seems
like it's never going to be resolved cuz
they've never made real they haven't
made progress over the last 20 years and
they've only detered like I don't want
to think about that because it's a lot
of suffering and it [__] with my mental
I I I can understand a lot of people
sentiment like that and for other people
they're like I have to care cuz if I
don't who's going to help these people
and I think all those opinions are valid
but I just I don't understand people who
want to impose their view on everyone
else demanding that they care about this
issue to me that just seems
counterproductive yeah that's that's you
you should care silence B